pas tout de suite prendre la direction
de kiev où nous attend gulliver crack
bonjour gulliver quelle est la situation
à l'heure actuelle est ce que vous
entendez toujours des explosions comme
cela a été entendu ce matin dans la
capitale ukrainienne
alors on en a entendu ce matin tôt et
puis j'en ai entendu un il y à quelques
minutes seulement il y a eu une grande
pause entre je sais pas autour du 7h du
matin et juste avant que je me mette en
place pour ce direct j'ai entendu un
seul
explosion je ne sais pas exactement
qu'est ce que c'était est-ce que c'était
loin en tout cas le centre ville de kiev
n'est pas en train d'être bombardés on
pense que ce sont des cibles militaires
à l'est de la ville il semble que à part
dans le dos de basse et dans le cas des
villes comme harkis ou personne ou une
invasion terrestre est clairement cours
je ne sais pas pourquoi les chinois
s'obstinent à nier qu'une invasion est
en cours à leurs clés à des temps qui
ont traversé la frontière mais sinon en
termes de frappe il semble effectivement
que des cibles militaires sont ciblés
uniquement mais vraiment sur toute
l'étendue de l'ukraine tout le
territoire de l'ukraine y compris dans
l'extrême ouest du pays
gulliver craag voilà pour la situation
sur le terrain effectivement à la russie
affirme que ce sont seulement des
objectifs militaires qui sont visés ce
qui est sûr effectivement c'est que tout
lui crâne et est visée par cette
intervention russe il n'y a pas
seulement l'est de l'ukraine avec les
républiques de donetsk et de loin ce que
quelle est la situation quelle est
l'atmosphère à kiev à l'heure à laquelle
on parle est ce qu'on peut sentir un
vent de panique on a découvert tout à
l'heure des images avec des
embouteillages monstres les personnes
les ukrainiens fui la capitale
ukrainienne
oui je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'ukrainiens qui cherchent à fuir il y a
aussi des ukrainiens qui veulent montrer
une position absolument stoïque des
fientes je devais aller en fait chez le
dentiste aujourd'hui je suis passé
devant juste pour dire que je ne venais
pas à ma grande surprise s'était ouvert
les réceptionnistes et l j'ai demandé
donc vous travaillez aujourd'hui bien
sûr elles ont répondu il y avait
clairement une décision que c'est une
position que l aller coûte que coûte
continuez donc il y à ces deux ces
attitudes divergentes selon la situation
personnelle de chacun je suppose le
président volodymyr zelensky a appelé à
tous les ukrainiens ayant de
l'expérience militaire de se présenter
pour aider
la cale à l'effort militaire contre
cette invasion l'ukraine a légalisé la
position d'armes à feu pour les civils
donc le président appelle à tout le
monde de faire le maximum d'efforts
qu'il peut mais je pense que lui mais
aussi comprends que beaucoup de
personnes ont envie en ce moment de
quitter la capitale et d'essayer de
trouver un abri un endroit plus sûr mais
où est ce que ce sera au vu de la carte
des attaques c'est un peu difficile de
déterminer où est ce que ce serait
l'endroit plus sûres ou allez merci
beaucoup guy lee burke ragués et l'on
continue bien sûr de suivre cette
situation